you
hi everyone is Jerry this is video 6
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
videos and we're going to have a look at
the four move checkmate we're going to
see how it can win at chess in just four
moves but not just that we're going to
see how we can defend against the
four-move checkmate in a convenient way
and we'll also learn about a couple
other things things that will help us to
put us in a correct frame of mind with
the game so let me first start out let
me go ahead and show you how you could
try to win in just four moves if you're
playing on the white side and you'd like
to use this form of checkmate what you
would do is target f7 this is the
weakest Square in the black position
since only the black King is there to
defend it and so what you're going to do
is have your Queen and light square
Bishop come out and converge on that
square so the way to begin is by moving
your EEP on up like so this is freeing
the way for both Bishop and Queen after
your opponent plays a move like 'if I've
a very common reply we bring our queen
out hitting f7 even throwing a punch of
this e5 pawn you can see Knight here or
even pawn here both of those actually
defendi five and we now bring our Bishop
out we have two pieces on this square
and if black is not careful making a
move like so something that might be
quite tempting since it's developing a
piece and attacking the Queen well black
has just fallen for the form of
checkmate Queen takes f7 and that's it
game over this has a name this form of
sequence it's known as the scholars mate
and I could tell you from firsthand
experience have been involved in the
game I've been playing the game long
enough to know that this has a great
great interest I'd see players over and
over again trying this and I imagine
many of them who try this and our
successful have a false sense of feeling
like their Grand Champion of the game
this is not accurate if you have players
out there who are trying this form of
checkmate and are successful they're not
grand champion of the game they're grand
champion of defeating
opponent who does not recognize a one
move threat um I too tried this same
thing let me say that much when I first
learned the game I tried this four move
check me over and over and over again
and I was never successful let me be
more specific
I learned the foot I learned this game
for my father he taught me the rules and
what did I do
I try to beat my father and for these
four moves and I was never successful in
fact I'd try it from a different angle I
wouldn't come out here and try to get
into that F 7 squared play here and then
put my Bishop here and okay if I move
like this happens that's another way you
could be winning but it was never
happening he would always see the one
move threat and develop and what am I
gonna do now this might have been the
early stage of me starting to think
ahead I recognized this Knights in the
way if he's not there I could checkmate
so I tried stuff like this I'm ready to
kick the night away he runs away and
then BOOM game over well timing is just
way off the knight comes here hits the
Queen reminds me that if I'm not careful
defending see - there goes my rook she's
never happening I was never successful
when I tried the four-move checkmate but
I still tried it over and over and over
again so I could only imagine the appeal
it will have for a player who does try
the form of checkmate and is successful
this form of checkmate is a form of hope
chess hope chess is when you make a
threatening move towards your opponent
even though you know it's bad and simply
hope that they won't respond well from
our previous videos we should know that
moving the Queen out early is a bad
choice we should be getting our minor
pieces out we should be getting castled
we should be developing efficiently
bringing the Queen out early is not a
wise choice we'll see how we could be
defending against this properly it's
important to put yourself in a correct
frame of mind we should be doing what we
feel is best in a chess game bringing
the Queen out early is not
best okay do not play hope chess is my
main point and it's important to be
asking ourselves the question what's the
threat this is the very basic the very
start of attack and defense in chess our
opponent generates some threat to our
excuse me makes a move the first
question you should be asking yourself
is what's the threat and once you've
correctly identified the threat the next
thing you should be looking to do is
determine how can I be defending against
the threat how can I be replying to a
threat in a convenient way so for
example in this position here how can
you reply to this attack against f7 in a
convenient way well it's the opening
stage of the game what would you
normally do if there wasn't a
maintenance right you would be
developing well if you can defend and
develop well that's convenient this is a
perfect way to be defending this
particular main threat in the initial
variation I showed with the Queen coming
out here this is fine bringing the Night
Out developing and after Bishop here
well this is not fine what would be
better what would be a way you can be
defending against the form of checkmate
in this case here's one way to do it
pawn to g6 notice we're looking for some
convenient way to defend against f7
Queen here this defends against f7 but
I'm not so sure that's convenient right
this bishop would really like to come
out and you're kind of stepping on one
another's toes you know the Queen being
here in the way of the bishop not really
such a great idea what about Queen here
well yeah that defends against f7 but
it's getting in the way of the night
we're looking for a convenient way and I
don't really see here here as being so
convenient Knight here well that defends
but we're looking to develop efficiently
is bringing the knight out to the edge
of the board a convenient way now
sometimes meeting a threat or a punch
with a counter punch is a good idea we
could do that in this position g6 is a
perfect way to defend against that
threat
and if the Queen comes here white
insists on attacking f7 along this file
now what can we do we can develop and
defend notice we wouldn't want to do
something like this this is not
developing this is inconveniencing our
own development Knight f6 is a perfect
way to do it and if white is super
excited about still pinpointing f7 only
this time with the bishop in this case
it would not be coming with well it
wouldn't be ending with checkmate but
white is threatening to take upon with
check well we can in fact ignore this
now and take advantage of the Queen's
decision that be coming out very early
we can improve our Knights position
enter the center with an attack against
the Queen also remind white that they
have to watch out for their c2 pond and
if Bishop takes pawn we move our King up
the Queen now has to move to a square
and still defend the bishop Queen here's
the only way to do it and we once again
hit the Queen she has to now leave the
defense of the bishop and when she does
there goes the bishop and black is the
winning side picking up a minor piece
and white only has a pawn to show for it
one other quick variation would run as
follows if at this point after Knight d4
if the Queen moves we would develop by
moving our pawn because this is freeing
the way for a new piece to come out and
if pawn takes here we bring our bishop
out the Queen is hit and when she moves
well this is going to be serious serious
trouble
white is in check and when the King
moves there goes the rook okay the main
point here is not to play hope chess not
to be doing things not to be threatening
your opponent even though you know it's
bad and simply hope that they won't
respond well bringing the Queen out
early is not a good decision and we need
to be asking our of ourselves the most
important question in chess which is
what what's the threat and we should be
looking at all times for a convenient
way to be replying to our opponents
threats in the early stage of the game
it will be to try and develop and defend
or maybe even develop and throw some
type of counter punch towards towards
our opponent
okay let me show you just a few other
quick ways you could be defending
against the four-move checkmate here's a
super simple way to do that if your
opponent starts off with this and you
know that they're very excited about
trying to beat you in four moves be six
there goes that form of checkmate when
the bishop comes here d5 that's a nice
way to slam the door in the bishops face
okay if this bishop is not seeing f7
directly you can kiss the four-move
checkmate goodbye same story goes for
starting out like this c6 Bishop here
where you go on Bishop you're not seeing
f7 directly you're not checkmating me in
four moves okay so those are just some
simple ways if you anticipate a player
like this trying to deliver checkmate if
four moves it's just not going to happen
the main thing is to stay into a correct
frame of mind here not play hope chess
make sure you're asking of yourself the
most important question in chess which
is what's the threat correctly identify
the threat and try your best to reply to
it in a convenient way okay so that's
all for this video as always I hope you
got something out of it and I will catch
you in video 7 take care bye
you